[Music]
so I'm Luis tough
I had a platform at blockchain today I'm
gonna be talking about how he brought
retail trading to 34 million
cryptocurrency wallets globally so first
off who is blockchain they may have
heard of the term Brenda Durant so we
are blockchain comm television company
and actually the world's leading digital
asset platform so we started out life as
a blockchain Explorer specifically for
Bitcoin and then we've evolved and grown
many products over the last five years
one of our most popular is our
cryptocurrency wallet we've also
launched a number of our consumer
products including the ability to trade
for two currency and we have data
products market research ap is for live
streaming data on blockchain analytics
and we've also launched a number of
institutional products I'll go into more
details on some of these later on the
presentation
so how do we compare it to the market
and who is our kind of main competition
so you may have heard of a company
called coinbase
so the difference between us and them is
that they focus more on the custodial
offering which means they are taking
custody of your digital assets and funds
and in return you can use our platform
and services for us we've taken a
noncustodial first approach which means
we're empowering users take full control
of their private keys and digital assets
at no point do we take ownership of
those and compromise your security or
privacy so that means you are no longer
reliant on a third party a centralized
entity or risk of any one person losing
or being compromised with your digital
assets and funds so our key aim really
is to empower users and educate them to
allow them to take control in a secure
and simple manner and our tagline here
you can see is B or n Bank we want every
user to consider becoming their own bank
and that is surprisingly easier said
than done so we have three main clients
we have an iOS Android and web platform
here are some screenshots of our iOS
application and I've highlighted some of
the key features functionality that our
mobile applications offer as I mentioned
these are owned long custodial so
they're fat clients or wallets so a lot
of the heavy lifting is done actually on
browser side or on the client themselves
our back-end is purely the store some
metadata and to interact with the
underlying blockchain network so here
you can see you have an overview of your
cryptocurrency assets your current
balances the live market price you have
the ability to buy and sell
cryptocurrencies will fit on and
off-ramps you can exchange your
cryptocurrencies for any other asset you
may be interested in and get live
pricing and I'm going to list a bit more
detail on the architecture behind that
and it finally common use case you can
send and receive cryptocurrency funds
very easily and very securely from right
within our mobile apps or from within
the web wallet and as I say you never
have to give up custody of your assets
to do this so where are we today so
right now we have 34 million wallets
globally and growing we're doing over 10
million new wallets a year currently
that equates to around a hundred
thousand transactions per day that are
being processed through our software
platform in total to date that's two
hundred billion dollars worth of
transactive ahlian has flown through our
software application and platform and I
think for me most excitingly that
actually accounts for 25% of the global
network traffic on the Bitcoin network
and finally we can't have a user base
that spans over 140 different countries
worldwide
so first up our Explorer so here on the
slide you can see we have this common
interface into many different underlying
block chains notably Bitcoin etherium
and Bitcoin cash right now there's three
main section on Explorer the first is
the input to look up your address your
transaction hash or a block second
middle section is key stats in
blockchain metrics such as the current
difficulty or the mempool size and
finally we have a real-time view of
incoming transactions and blocks that
are being mined so I want to delve now
bit deeper into what does it take to run
a web platform like that and how do we
achieve in real-time the stream of data
from these on the line chains and more
importantly how do I do that at scale
for getting around two and half thousand
requests per minute consistently and
that kind of Peaks even higher with kind
of significant price movements
so how does it work so this is obviously
simplified overview but as I mentioned
we have three main consumers of our
platform so that is our mobile wallets
on iOS Android and the web we have our
Explorer which I just showed on a pure
slide and we also have a number of
public api's where any individual
company can build on top of our platform
and they can actually use it for
creating transactions sending receiving
and also just consuming and adjusting
the blockchain data directly without
having to do the kind of hard work of
integrating with the underlying chains
and we're in the middle we have this
data ingestion service platform so
internal to us we built out a number of
services that are responsible for
interacting with the underlying chains
such as Bitcoin
etherium cash stellar etc so we create a
wrapper around these that interacts with
the low-level API is that they provide
we actually spin up and run all of our
own notes in GCP and we have a number of
our servicing opponents that then ingest
all of the real-time blocks and
transactions extract the key insights
and metrics do any kind of
transformations we need and persist that
within a relational database we then
serve that back up to our clients on
demand at scale between that we do have
caching layers and a number of other
technologies to mitigate issues at scale
which I will go into a bit further but a
key thing here is that a lot of the
complexity of pulling out a very simple
attribute like your balance is
abstracted away from the user both in
terms of the UI and UX experience you
get from within our clients but also for
our unified API so you no longer have to
spin up your own node come a part of the
public network understand their api's
which are often pretty low level
interpret the data which again is
usually at a lower level of abstraction
now you just have one API to interact
with to seamlessly send receive and
process all the blockchain data
so how do we evolve so I wanted to set a
scene on our scale of our infrastructure
to support our platform both the
Explorer could critic currency wallet
and a number of other products so you
see here we're running over two and a
thousand cores currently in DCP and
around nine terabytes of virtual memory
you can see the graph the wallet
accounts they've been created over the
last five six years have grown
tremendously especially since 2017 when
a news kind of hit mainstream and
cryptocurrencies were suddenly being
discussed by every single person on the
street I think astonishingly and
something that we realized wasn't going
to scale was that a third of our
infrastructure was dedicated to our
in-memory
NDB cluster and this was running our
Explorer and our cryptocurrency wallets
to the backbone for all those and it was
done ourselves by our engineering team
so we're using most predominantly
compute engine and running all this
stuff ourselves as scale as many of you
will know that doing that beyond a point
becomes extremely costly but from a
monetary perspective but also from the
operational overhead of maintaining it
upgraded it and dealing with the fallout
of failures so we ran over 24 nodes the
bacon are in redundancy and make sure we
our fault torrent and to do any kind of
scaling we cannot scale linearly or on
demand we had to actually spin up a
whole new cluster alongside our
production cluster restore each of the
underlying chains for example the
Bitcoin blockchain from the beginning
and now take around one week all being
well and then once it caught up we can
then flick the switch and move our
applications over to the new Russian
cluster because of the pain involved and
the time it took to do this we were just
last year just doubles our
infrastructure overnight just to support
our exponential growth
not as quickly realized that this is not
sustainable so beginning of last year we
started to consider what are the other
options we have here and how can we
reduce the operational overhead of
running this at scale and ensuring that
our infrastructure was going to support
us on our mission to grow and we define
can a financial infrastructure of the
world so in comes Clyde spanner so we
looked at a number of different products
and we decided to try a prototype and
PSC on Clyde spanner that impressive
thing here is that within a few minutes
we were able to spin out the production
cluster and have strong consistency
globally distributed at scale and all of
that for a marginal increase in cost as
to running just compute engine and
management infrastructure ourselves so
early signs were promising
we then switched and we architect our
application started to reinvent our
schema and it started to actually go
all-in on Clyde spanner initially for
our Bitcoin blockchain ingestion process
one of the key things we did early on
which really benefited engineering team
is that we connected with the class
banner team directly so we had a few
conversations with technical PM Deepti
and a number of engineers in her team
and they've already helped us through
the initial hurdles of getting set up on
a brand new technology and really
understanding the nuances of where is
gonna work and some of the constraints
of running at scale we had to make some
design decisions early on that we've had
that help would have been costly to
change later I think one of the key
features that really benefited us during
this iterative development process was
the fact that we can now the full import
and export in record time so we could
back up our whole database in just 30
minutes
as I mentioned before it took one week
to restore that we can now do it in a
batch job overnight in just
1/2 hours so what this meant is that we
could rapidly develop our application
and services do a lot of testing and
playing around with different schemas
and architectures and also once we're
happy we could then promote that through
each of the environments dev staging pre
fraud and then finally to production and
now it's simple quick and efficient
you'll notice here as well that we have
this is our production comparison to
have under half of the original nodes
that we needed before
now just ten nodes and all the reasons
for that is because you're getting
redundancy high availability strong
consistency and global replication as
part of the package
and if finally we could scale on-demand
so at a touch of a button we could
double our infrastructure we could also
set predefined thresholds and have that
elastic on-demand final thing is we
actually leveraged table interleaving
which meant that we could take some of
the complex queries we're running
against our NDB cluster previously and
reduce the time it took to run those
from 30 seconds down to around 15
milliseconds so the whole migration was
hugely impactful for us and our products
and now we've been running this for rent
six months in production overall on
average I just did a comparison before
it came and we are saving around 30%
month on month in terms of the at Dollar
Man which is pretty impressive when
usually some of the hesitation of I'm
using to software as a service and
Sony's cloud services is the expense
it's going to just creep up as you grow
but actually we've seen the opposite
we've not only reduced the operational
overhead of managing mr. Skell we've
also made our CFO very happy
so how else is this data set used and
one of our products do we offer as I
mentioned earlier we build out a crypto
the crypto exchange product again
leveraging a number of client services
and operating at a significant scale so
this allows you to exchange a cross
chain transactions and get live exchange
like pricing right from a VIN you're
noncustodial wallet so again you never
have to send your funds anywhere and
give up the custody of your assets to
any one individual company or entity
your private keys remain with you on
your device or in your browser here's a
quick demo of the product so this is on
one of our mobile applications you'd
simply just type in the amount you wish
to sell or buy you'd get a live pricing
right from within the app in real time
and you can exchange between mobile
pairs that we offer you finally have a
summary screen confirm and that's it
so what's really going on and what are
some of the complexities with building
out this hair for your degree smooth
user experience so the key challenges
security so for us blockchain as a
company security is our number one
priority in everything we do you may
have heard of some of the horror stories
from cryptocurrency companies in a space
that have been hacked compromised or
lost their users funds we don't be a
next headline so everything we do goes
for a very rigorous process volatility
so in the marketplace if any of you
follow the cryptocurrency pricing you'll
see that it's extremely volatile maybe
swinging by 20 to 50 percent in a day so
how do you create a smooth user
experience when the price is jumping
around all over the place the first
challenge public network I think it's an
important one now we are relying on
infrastructure that is outside of our
control we're no longer just relying on
our private
network within GCP and the services that
we've built we now have to broadcast in
centers actions over network and many
nodes globally distributed so whether
can some of the constraints when you do
that and it finally high availability I
think it's kind of a given for any
challenge company now but it's worth
noting how do you achieve that at scale
and again what are some of the design
decisions an architectural decision you
have to make early on to ensure you
achieve that so the interesting part how
does it work someone's give you a little
bit of information on what's under the
hood and how does the architecture
actually look this is a slight
simplification but it gives you a very
good idea by some of the core components
and interactions between those we do
leverage a number of cloud services to
achieve this and I'll mention where they
fit into the stack but as you saw on the
previous slide first of all we start
with a client so Android iOS or web you
didn't have a secure connection to our
back-end while our client gateways and
the user will connect to the swap
product initiate a secure web site
connection and as we'll start streaming
live prices to their device these are
types in the volume they wish to sell or
buy and we then adjust our pricing based
upon that input we have a liquidity an
execution engine which is the driving
force of all of our trading activity and
that has connections to many different
exchanges market makers and brokers and
also our internal imagery that's
managing risk portfolio management and
pricing internally as well we've also
built our own custodial solution there's
a multi-tiered
custody solution on which the hot wallet
is at a table stack so this is the only
part of it or layer that is
programmatically accessible and secure
in our internal network all lovers are
air-gapped and have a number of other
security policies and pastes so once the
users happy of the price
the hit exchange what happens next so
our client gateways will go off to our
liquidity engine and say hey I want to
execute a trade to sell half a Bitcoin
liquid the engine will then lock in the
price and send back how much of the
counter currency they wish to receive so
that's for example say I want to sell
Bitcoin for aetherium in parallel we
initiate a request to our hot wallet
which is the gateway to all of our nodes
so these are the blockchain nodes
stellar xlm Bitcoin beacon cash etherium
etc will then generate a deposit address
which the hot wallet service will
persist and start listening on for any
incoming deposits we then combine these
transactions send it back to the client
and the client name returns to the user
the final amount they need to send us to
receive their etherium and amp reliant
side the browser and/or the mobile
client will construct that transaction
and sign it using their private keys and
then broadcast that out to the
underlying respective network
none of that touches our back-end that's
well done client side as mentioned
earlier now it will be sent and
broadcast across the public network and
we wait patiently for that to hit a
network broadcast event and a
confirmation event and the hot water is
responsible for that once those have
been received off the public network we
then use Kafka as our main message bus
so you have an advantage of an
architecture so this sends an event over
Kafka one of the consumers is our client
gateways that picks it up and in purses
that we then compare that against our
state machine transition through the
lifecycle say hey deposit received we
now need to Pender withdrawal we update
the user and say hey we receive your
deposit we're now going to initiate the
request for you we then make a call back
to the whole wallet and send the amount
we wish to withdraw and the deposit
address that was sent from the client
originally
again that's them broadcast out on the
public network the client will then
receive the funds in due course usually
within half an hour and we notify them
via push by email SMS I mean one of the
interesting cases that happen recently
is that these public blockchains can
have many different use cases apart from
just transferring a store value and one
of them is actually being a leverage for
marketing so what that means is actually
every time anyone sends a transaction on
a Bitcoin cash network and someone is
listening because you have this public
ledger they're listening for this
address any new address that appears
they didn't send you a little marketing
message and what does that mean
materially it means that actually we as
a company on a repositories receive more
funds than the user actually sent and
also the user receives slightly more
funds than we send them they also
receive two transactions that are one so
this was kind of a very interesting use
case where we had to be flexible and
defensely program for this in the future
and finally the the note gateway to the
bottom are really the data ingestion
service platform that I mentioned
previously and our our way of wrapping
each of the underlying blockchain notes
so one of the other interesting things
that we've managed to do is build out a
hardware device which is a secure way of
storing your cryptic currency assets
offline this has full instruments with
all of our platform and software so you
can use our swap product as I show you
before and your keys never have to leave
the physical device so this is hugely
beneficial to all users who are security
conscious and maybe they'll trust the
terminal or workstation they're using
and we've managed to achieve this
leveraging our existing interface and
software some of the key benefits of
using Google so I mentioned a few of
these already but I wanted to kind of
summarize and highlight these before
finishing up so one of the things that
GSP is really allowed us to do is scale
up our infrastructure on demand when
you're dealing with tens of millions of
what accounts globally it's important
that you're not constrained by the
infrastructure that you are using we've
had many cases when the prices moved
significantly and suddenly the number of
users that were onboarding everyday has
gone up five or ten times and we've had
to actually scale poor infrastructure
significantly during those periods I
mean in the peaks of the last few months
we've seen over a hundred thousand new
wallets being created every single day
and up to 101 million in a given week so
the significant strains on our
infrastructure that we have to account
for and one of the things we do do as I
mentioned previously is adding a number
of caching layers take a lot of
advantage of CDN and do a lot of load
balancing across many instances for a
most part all of our infrastructure is
stateless so means we can horizontally
scale it on demand
also on the previous architecture we're
leveraging cloud services where possible
it means that our team can focus and
hone in on some of our very specific
domain complexities and challenges and
don't worry about running our
infrastructure scale and solving the
problems that Google have been doing for
many years
today it spend less time energy and
effort Imaginarium structure and more
time focusing on building what we
believe to be the future of Finance as I
mentioned we have high availability so
we're leveraging cloud sequel that we're
leveraging spanner we use a number of
other services quite broadly across our
architecture as you can imagine we have
a lot of American micro services within
our architecture so being able to just
quickly spin up a highly available
redundant and scalable database at a
click of a button it is very powerful
and we're using both Postgres and MySQL
engines for that our third point is that
it's engineering friendly I think all of
our engineers whatever their skill set
or focus enjoy the GCP experience
whether that's because of using the CLI
and programmatically writing scripts
around that or using the interface
itself to dive into problems and
debugging issues and finally the fourth
one which I mentioned earlier of our
spanner story is the technical support I
think a lot of people didn't realize the
amount of support that Google offer you
as a company we can tap into a wealth of
knowledge and domain expertise through
our camera managers and customer
engineers and we do that pretty
regularly we've had many conversations
comparing Google products to other open
source technologies and the pros and
cons of using them so another story that
happened last year we were just trying
to decide on the correct message bus
architecture for this training product
and for
many others one of our key requirements
was sequencing so we then spoke with the
technical PM's from the pops up team and
had a real candid conversation about
what were the pros and cons of using
pub/sub above Kafka and a net result of
that conversation was that we used Kafka
and that was their recommendation I mean
it's quite refreshing when you can
actually connect with the engineers at a
cloud company and they recommend a
product which they do not support or
sell themselves
[Music]
you
[Music]